Virtual Reality and Augmented Reality are two technologies changing the way we use screens,...
...creating new and exciting interactive experiences.
Virtual Reality, also known as VR uses a headset with a built-in screen...
...that displays a virtual environment for you to explore.
These headsets use a technology called "head tracking"...
...which allows you to look around the environment by simply moving your head.
Augmented Reality or AR is a bit different.
Instead of transporting you to a virtual world,...
...it takes digital images and layers them on the real world around you.
This is done through the use of either a clear visor or a smartphone.
So with VR, you could explore a world full of dinosaurs.
But with AR, you could see those dinosaurs moving through the world around you.
Both of these technologies are growing at a rapid pace...
...and being implemented in a variety of different ways.
Surgeons are using VR to practice highly technical surgeries before operating.
Businesses are using them to give consumers virtual tours of products and locations.
There are even apps that can use your smartphone's camera...
...to scan and translate a foreign language in real time.